hi amazon hat ein kleines dankeschön
geschickt denn mein letztes amazon
beauty adventskalender unboxing hatte
einfach mal 400.000 aufrufe und waren
ganzen tag auf platz 1 in den trends da
kriegt doch das marketing wahlgang
fetten applaus
jetzt habe ich diesen adventskalender
nochmal zugeschickt bekommen und ich
dachte mir an verschenke ich ihnen an
jemanden den ich liebe die mir am herzen
liegt und dem ich eine freude machen
möchte oder drehe ich nochmal ein
unboxing und lande vielleicht noch mal
auf platz 1 für den trend mit einem
amazon adventskalender video einmal muss
hauptsache keine türkische soap fesche
burschen
also lehnt euch zurück und holte und
meldete mich bitte nicht bei
irgendwelchen bewerten wenn das hier ist
kein werbevideo ich bekomme kein geld
ich habe einfach nur diesen kalender
bekommen
dankeschön amanpour aber er findet
natürlich in der verliert link unten in
der video beschreibung falls ihr euch
den selber holen bolden ist da gibt es
keine einzige in kästchen dafür ein
bisschen art und ja an alle leute die
mögen habt ihr das karibische meer video
gesehen
oh mein gott diese frau hat das schönste
und beste art und er video aller zeiten
kreiert das habe ich mir so oft zum
schlafen an weil sie so gut ins mikrofon
spricht dass ich immer schon nach einer
minute einschlafe die vorderseite
rückseite und die beiden seiten haben
fächer und wir packen jetzt aus wales
die nummer 1 letztes jahr hat mir der
inhalte richtig gut gefallen
red bull winter edition zwetschge zimt
nelke um eine kleine zint may dass er
voll fitte kinder county und hanuta für
das erste türchen kopf
sehr viel vor die nummer zwei okay es
ist praktisch in der weihnachtszeit
brauche ich vanillin zucker und roma
romani rose mit drei mann ist es jetzt
immer auf der anderen seite war was er
braucht
ich sag mal so viele jüngere generation
ist das glaube ich nicht weil er kennt
ihren kinder das war eines der ziele
sagt mensch weil ich immer 4 nummer 44
mensch deutschen luft haben das ist
jetzt das diät wacker ist nix drin ich
meine vom tag davor hat man doch so viel
mehr den walnüssen zu tun ich habe mir
nie an einem tag
vor 50 jahren gegen fünf mensch zu
mensch sein korn jeweils für den campus
kämpfe immer zum snacken ok ok servierte
ich habe mir schon so lange servierte da
ist sogar kleine weihnachtsmann
reservierte unten weihnachtsmann
[Musik]
es ist nikolaus amazon weiß wie man sie
verwöhnt das ist gelogen was uns
reserviert wird ja bist ja wenn ich
jetzt sage sie derer wäre den wird sich
so richtig schön darüber aufregen ich
muss auch jetzt böse im modus in dem es
bio titel schreiben und amazon
das war ernst die habe ich das so
verbiete servierte sie irgend als
höchstes also leute was wird drin sein
nicht oder schreibt ihr könnt jetzt ein
trinkspiel machen nichts oder schritte
müssen jetzt mal trinken wenn's schaut s
oder nichts
letschkow ist irgendwie beides den für
nicht gut hass nämlich nein ich mag ein
fahrgast und ich will irgendwann eine
einpacker farm haben denn dürfen aber
auch ein panamas schafe und ziegen zu
kommen weil ich grenze da niemanden aus
ich finde auch bei tieren ist rassismus
echt viel platz deswegen everybody's
bekam ich darf ja gar nicht beschweren
ich habe ihn ja umsonst bekommen ich
freue mich da
[Musik]
das finde ich gut
rother häufen man kann aber auch zum
beispiel kleine weihnachtshütte machen
nützen körper 100 lauren müsliriegel ich
bin rumpeln ein missliebiger kann man
nie genug haben chips ist immer cool
die firma jetzt den red bulls die partie
ganz außen probier gar nichts das geht
raus und euch meine kleinen zwischen
zimt nelken nicht schmeckt gut
hätte ich nicht gedacht dass ich hätte
meine freundin hat noch mal so eine
schrankwand unglaublich wieder typen da
von diesen ungarischen chips drin
wer sich die kindheit türchen nummer
zwei also ernsthaft lebenserwartung
sachen happy valley
ich muss sagen ich mag eine warnliste
deswegen freue ich mich gerade über eine
gemischte tüte sein heim 0 13
auch männer schnell kolator da braucht
es ist ja ganz auf viele sowie gerne
sachen und so nicht wenn wir das gefühl
dass diese jemand zu rewe reingegangen
ist gehört hat collapse müsliriegel den
resten kreise und einfach noch mal gar
nix eine materie veganisch schokolade
das ist klasse ich muss sagen ich bin
noch nicht in dem alter in dem ich so
das hat mit der schokolade feiert ihr 15
ihr seht es vor mir
[Musik]
samira amazon danke die sorge andere
schokolade bei aber ich interessiere
mich nur für die servierte du kannst die
servierten sammeln und dann gibt es so
ein kleber buch da kannst du alle deine
servierten rein kleben und nicht
umbringen so viel salz model ich würde
es dinge und falls ihr euch jetzt
gefragt hat wo ich so lange war die
letzten tage
ich habe ziemlich viel zu tun was nicht
mit youtube zu tun hat und deswegen
hatte ich einfach keine zeit videos zu
machen und das kommt mir gerade sehr gut
denn ersten wir mal ehrlich das ist kein
aufwand
genauso wie die adventskalender mandl
nougat creme und haselnuss krim danke so
was klaut ihm auch in hotels beim
frühstück wie sie jedoch wieder zuerst
schauen
[Musik]
ach kein müsli riegel sondern ein
veganes zuckerfreies uns lief an diesem
morgen kannst du natürlich das vermissen
die essen an einem anderen morgen
bekommst du eine cola zum frühstück gar
nichts das ganze budget ging
wahrscheinlich für die hieraus da musste
man sparen bei der tür 18 klasse 9h
obwohl thematisch gerne 20
gleich mal die bahn
also dieser werte wie werde ich prügel
und dann an weihnachten benutzen
21 manuka honig honig 22
no - ich hab' wein müsse man will
und beides und man den eingang zum der
coach ich sag mal so geht immer mehr
man habe jetzt auch gebraucht nach
diesem streifen honig blecker womit will
uns amazon an weihnachten verwöhnen wir
schaut zuerst wenn du es nicht dass wir
sie an weihnachten gerade hand möchte
18 mal ehrlich sind ach du scheiße wenn
doch irgendwann zwei fächern mehr das
heißt es muss man jetzt hier irgendwas
rumfliegen holt euch nicht den amazon
zur preiser dance kalender nazis
preislich belohnt ich denke nicht seiner
kreativ und machte teuren eltern
geschwistern euren liebsten einen
eigenen adventskalender dieses jahr
wisst ihr was haben guten job nimmt er
seine servierte sagt mir meine mama mag
am liebsten die leitung des kriegs ihr
dann packten die leitung steaks verein
macht war ein schönes band rumhängen
gewonnen weil und schon ab märz können
oder ihr macht es wie amazon und glück
ein servierte und packt an den
proportionen luft rein macht es zu ganz
vorsichtig wie ronja die lücken nicht
entweichen lassen
mit dem seil drum und kind jetzt auch
anhängt und dann öffnet eure mama am
nikolaus zum tüchern sagte gar nichts
letztes jahr war es nicht ein größerer
fan von
adventskalender weil da wird nicht so
viele produkte drin waren wo ich immer
dachte mein geschenkten gaul schaut man
nicht ins maul
wenn ihr mir auch instagram volk dann
verlor sich diese packungen herum ganz
toll für und kuchen rum pralinen einfach
auch so als schrott kann man es genießen
mehr kein alkohol drin
noch kurz zu meiner abwesenheit die euch
wahrscheinlich gar nicht so aufgefallen
ist mir selbst ich hab gerade halt echt
und rapid zu tun neben youtube und
deswegen hätten dass friedrich schwer
ein video oder regelmäßiges rauszuhauen
ist aber nicht mehr gelang
ich plane schon wieder schön dezember
eigentlich jeden tag ein video
rauszuhauen ich habe es bis jetzt kein
mal geschafft durchzuziehen aber ganz
ehrlich ich gebe nicht auf